on the campaign trail tonight creepy
sleepy crazy Uncle Joe well he has
become well-known for all the wrong
reasons now his head scratching gaffes
are now a constant consistent
embarrassment almost every day he didn't
remember what state he was in this past
weekend of course is awkward touching
hugging beyond cringe-worthy pretty
gross to me his small crowds at crowds
in New Hampshire Iowa are now causing
major concern inside the Democratic
Party establishment his debate
performances are beyond lackluster and
tonight
we're going to expose something much
more troubling for Joe Biden and his
2020 ambitions now while millions of
Americans struggle to make ends meet
under the anaemic Biden Obama economy
remember 13 million more Americans food
stamps eight million more poverty lowest
labor participation rate since the 70s
that was their record well his family
members were allegedly profiting off of
his powerful position many of them in
2014 at the very same time Vice
President Biden was leading the Obama
administration's policy in Ukraine well
the son hunter he took a lucrative
position on the board of a major
Ukrainian gas company he was reportedly
making $50,000 a month even though he
had zero experience in the gas industry
no experience in the country of Ukraine
now the arrangement was beyond sketchy
and according to John Solomon the
Washington Examiner
well John Kerry's step so to work with
hunter Biden in the investment industry
cut all business ties with his former
partner he wanted no part of this and
that's not all in May of 2016 the
Ukrainian energy company that has
shelled out a fortune to Hunter Biden
was facing a major corruption
investigation by Ukraine's top
prosecutor in response Oh vice president
then Vice President Joe Biden threatened
to withhold over a billion dollars in US
loan guarantees your tax money using it
as leverage if Ukraine didn't fire the
prosecutor that was looking into that
gas company that was paying his son all
this money and ultimately Ukraine
relented too Biden's demand and sleepy
creepy crazy Uncle Joe he
about the whole thing on camera watch
this we're not going to give you the
million dollars they said you have no
authority you're not the president the
president said I said call I think it
was six hours I looked I said leave in
six hours if the prosecutors not fired
you're not getting the money oh the guy
that was four investigating the company
that was paying a son a fortune Senate
no experience by the way that's not the
only case I told you about the China
influence another corruption especially
Peter Schweitzer's book goes into great
great detail about that and according to
Politico in 2015 Biden's younger brother
James well he received a generous half a
million dollar loan from a wealthy donor
also with deep ties to Ukraine now more
recently James Biden was accused of
offering medical companies special
access to his own brother